Jay Bilas ESPN college basketball
analyst good morning Jay how are you
good morning Dan how are you I'm
spectacular to meet Friday by the way
didn't know if you're celebrating that
where you live but it it's a big deal
here
well I'm everything you celebrating
you're here my beacon there thank you
am i celebrating the $125,000 contract
to the elite high school basketball
prospects today yeah I think it's
another option but I don't think it's a
it's necessarily a game changer there's
gonna be a lot that's gonna be said
about it and I think there's some
celebration in the NC double-a office
because they can now say hey if you
don't like you know what we're serving
then go somewhere else you know you can
go under the G League nobody's forcing
you to go to college but then when
compas you know when the one-and-done
rule is brought up and they say well we
shouldn't have anybody forced to go to
college and so you kind of ask them well
which is it I don't I don't think it's a
bad thing to have that option I just
don't think you're gonna see some exodus
into the G League for 125,000 how do we
decide whose elite for these select
contracts for the G League that's kind
of a problem I think it'll be the NBA
deciding who they want more than
anything but but that's an open question
and a really good one and you know you
you're you're having a lot of things
converge now after the FBI investigation
started right about a year ago or at
least was revealed about a year ago with
all the charges you know all of a sudden
we had everything turned upside down
Condoleezza Rice came in with Mark
Emmert Commission and we had all these
recommendations of USA basketball needs
to hold camps and the shoe companies
need to be cordoned off we'll take their
money but we don't want them you know
talking to the players that kind of
thing
you know we're having a lot of a lot of
barriers being put up right now and I
don't really know how it's going to
shake out but they're clearly what's
clearly happening is they're trying to
separate the best players so the team
but really the incidentally can continue
to blame all their pre-existing problems
on want it done it's really remarkable
how we've done this we've said that you
know yes definitely said well people
have no interest to go to school by the
one and done rule being forced to go to
school and nobody really looks at the
other side of it of saying well who's
forcing you to take them nope
forcing you to recruit one-and-done
players if they're not interested in
school nobody's forcing you to admit
them in school and nobody's forcing you
to give them a uniform if they're not
doing their homework and not taking the
classes you think they should take so if
there's a lot of a lot of contradictions
and hypocrisy going on here but if I
looked at last year's talent and Marvin
Bagley does he go to Duke or would he
take $125,000 you know deandre Aten is
he at Arizona now Zion Williamson this
year could you see these kids passing up
the opportunity to play on national TV
and whatever advance their brand or
would they rather take the 125 and play
in relative obscurity probably not and
this is the this is really the issue dad
like like the G League is a minor league
and the incidentally likes to say well
they don't want to be another minor
league well they're not a minor league
there are major league
I mean minor leagues don't make billions
of dollars don't have multi billion
dollar TV contracts so I think the
answer is the elite prospect would
prolly go to college especially since
they're getting paid anyway a lot of
them so know they can take and do both I
mean you know people are it amazing this
trial is going on you've got wiretap
evidence that's being laid bare at open
court and nobody cares like the fans
don't care clearly the n-c-double-a
don't care and all these presidents and
athletic directors that shake their
fists all the time and say integrity
integrity integrity nobody has been put
on administrative leave nobody has been
fired you know nothing's happened it's
just a bunch of people saying well you
know nobody from the federal government
has contacted us and we're really
looking forward to a great season I
don't really want to hear lectures from
college administrators anymore about
what integrity means it's really it's
really laughable but you got some names
attached to this you know Bill Self his
name attached to a twenty thousand
dollar payment to recruit and normally
coach it does it never gets to a head
coach it's rare when it gets to a head
coach it's almost like by accident that
a head coach is named in something like
this what Zion williamson's stepdad you
know allegedly asked for from Kansas so
like where are we going with this
investigation and is anybody going to be
put on probation
or Zion Williamson's eligibility in
question it feels like there's there's a
lot of unanswered questions out there
and I agree with you I don't know if
anybody cares they don't and there are a
lot of unanswered questions a ton of
them and I can tell you one thing
they're not going to be answered this
season
part of it is because the government has
asked the n-c-double-a to stand down as
far as investigations are concerned but
that doesn't mean individual schools can
investigate their own players and and
you know there the truth is Dan there's
there's really no way or compliance to
to get to the bottom of all this stuff
it's got to be it's going to be the
n-c-double-a and we're never going to
get the answers to all this stuff all
the all the players that are implicated
right now are going to be long gone
before this is ever settled and and you
know you can say like what what more
would a school need to say hey we need
to do something and then evidence of
their coach or of an assistant coach
being on a wiretap and what you need to
be like CSI Miami to figure this out you
don't it's it's clear not only what the
implication is it's clear what this is
it's race tips elope whether it is what
it appears to be and I'm just I'm
surprised that we're getting all this
nonsense about well you know the federal
government's not going to contact people
in the middle of a trial so that just
doesn't happen so they're saying well we
have been contacted yet as if this stuff
does if this stuff doesn't matter it
matters according to their rules and
they say the rules are above everything
that they believe in integrity and all
this other stuff and you know they
g-league made an announcement yesterday
at Mark Emmert had a statement out in no
time
NC double-a coaches are revealed on
wiretaps and it's crickets out of
Indianapolis and I find that I find that
kind of hard hard to stomach it's Jay
Bilas ESPN college basketball analyst
joining us i I'm just amazed that how
much you know these administrators
educators care about these kids from you
know urban areas like we really really
care about them only for one year
instead of saying if we really cared we
would let them go right to the pros and
you know then we wouldn't have this
charade with college basketball but this
comes down to I think it's just a
billion-dollar business and we need is
many new and shiny toys is possible so
March Madness lives up to its billing I
mean it doesn't come down to just that -
the bottom line with a lot of this stuff
here Jay I think so but also Dan I think
it goes deeper than that I think the
n-c-double-a would really like to see
all of the top prospects that are the
quote one and done not come to college
at all so they can they can wash their
hands of the whole thing and they can
say we're about education where in my
judgment if you're really about
education you would welcome everybody to
college and and try to get them to do
both to pursue their dream to be a
professional and to good to get their
education now that's what educated
that's what true educators do and but
all of this is being done in the name of
money the n-c-double-a will do whatever
it takes so they do not have to pay
that's all this is there are every
argument is being tailored so they don't
have to pay and none of it makes any
sense and especially like Andy Schwartz
is a terrific
economist wrote an amazing article on
Deadspin that sort of talked about how
the n-c-double-a has been gaslighting
all of us for all these years and they
move the goalposts every time they're in
court and under oath and I think it's
worth a read that illuminate just how
bad these arguments are in favor of
amateurism which a burger isn't there's
nothing for any athlete doesn't make
them a better athlete doesn't make them
a better person doesn't make them a
better student we cared about education
we'd be incentivizing players to come to
school and stay in school especially
since the overwhelming majority of
players in in college basketball or
african-american III think there's I
think there's a lot of things that are
frankly shameful and the responses were
capitalist your former coach Coach K
called the investigation going on just a
blip which I was really I was really
surprised that Coach K would call it
just a blip your reaction to that I
would differ with him on that I think
it's far more than a blip this has been
going on for a long long time I think
there's a lot of a lot of space between
blip and everybody is doing it I don't
think I don't think anybody would argue
that every single coach is doing it but
but the idea that you have the 30th best
player in the country or 30th
player in the country getting $100,000
to go to Louisville and nobody else is
getting that and that's just a blip I
think is I can't imagine that be it true
I think anybody who's been around it
would acknowledge that there's the
cheating going on forever in basketball
and football
I mean people seem to forget that you
know an agent paid Reggie Bush and you
know Cam Newton there was there's all
kinds of cheating going on in football I
mean one of the ways that it's being
done now is with debit cards with
offshore offshore accounts so they can't
be traced this stuff is really
sophisticated and and you know the
government is trying to say that the
schools are victims when the school's
coaches and a lot of these instances not
only know about it in certain instances
they're in on it so it's hard to imagine
how they could be painted as victims and
they'll be really interesting to see
what this jury does with that theory
wait so these kids will get an ATM card
and then they can take out money and
that money is is put in offshore so
there's no trail
yeah the offshore accounts that's what
I'm told I mean I don't I don't know I'm
not involved in that stuff but that's
what I've been told over the years is
that's the latest thing that's going on
on the football side and look no I mean
can you not talk about this well we were
in school you know boosters were the
issue money being funneled the players
buy boosters yeah so it's become much
more sophisticated now so you know the
instable I could say well we really
cleaned up the booster thing but then
they got unbound the basketball side the
shoe companies in grassroots basketball
and all these things because the high
school players and the college players
are too the shoe companies more valuable
than the pros they move more product and
opposed do and so no and in football it
strains the mind to think that players
are being paid at basketball and the the
the sport that Dwarfs it financially and
basketball makes billions it but the
sport that Dwarfs it no everything's
clean the last guy that's the last guy
that was caught cheating was Cam Newton
and Reggie Bush and everything else is
clean that's laughable it's just not
true
yeah it's it's crazy it really is of
what it is and where it is and where
it's going and I I just wonder is the
clock ticking on the one in
done is there a time frame do you think
yeah but it's gonna it's going to be in
the next collective bargaining agreement
so be twenty two thousand twenty one or
two thousand okay - so this is a nice
stopgap you know the g-league thing but
the truth is Dan they're not going to
put a limit on it so they're not going
to make you stay in school for two or
three years like they do it's football
which is an old vestige but what will
happen is you'll see players
reclassifying like Marvin bag Luther did
last year and leave after one year
anyway so we're not gonna be able to
stop players getting after one year
they'll just have no it doesn't or so
maybe more that take off but then you're
gonna have others that are gonna are
gonna blossom as freshmen and they're
gonna be gone after one year - that's
not going to eliminate the problem
it's going to eliminate a few of the
players and that's the thing it's it's
not problem solving
it's just player movement of play of you
players now what do you think LeBron
would have been worth on the open market
like I mean are you talking about
wrecking under the table payment oh yeah
oh it's on yeah but that's the thing and
like the money's flowing anyway and work
we've developed this fiction but that we
can stop the flow of money in the
multi-billion dollar business and I
always think about that movie Jurassic
Park where the Jeff Goldblum character
would say life finds away and it's the
same thing in this kind of business
money binds away and you've heard my
mind stuff on this I mean if this were
really a murder we wouldn't be selling
it for billions of dollars like amateur
sports don't make billions of dollars
don't pay their coaches millions this is
professional it's not minor-league its
major league and the only thing that is
not professional about it is the way the
players are treated they don't they
don't have the same economic rights as
the students they are going to school
with who are allowed scholarships and
whatever their talents command in the
marketplace it's it's really kind of a
bizarre system but the truth is like
like we were saying before the fans
don't care they just want their games
you know it's like conference
realignment you know they don't care
about how much coaches are paid
conference realignment they just want
their games when they want their games
they want to watch them they want to fed
on them they want to enjoy them
and they don't really care like I don't
I didn't care whether the officials in
the NFL got their pensions a few years
ago I just wanted the games and it's the
same thing with with college athletes
the fans don't care what they're paid or
not they just want this game's safe
travels Jay we appreciate your time
thanks for joining us thank you brother
all right that's Jay Bilas you know
there's a lot of questions with this and
he's right I don't know if these kids
are gonna pass up going to Duke or North
Carolina or Kansas or you know fill in
the blank to make 125,000 but if you
make 125 and you're a mark like Zion
Williamson making 125 and then all of a
sudden adidas or Nike comes in and says
now we can pay you ten million dollars
huh instead of waiting a year to get
sponsor you're gonna get money under the
table and these guys do you know there's
a sophistication but I think it comes
back to the shoe companies and you're
finding that out in this trial because
if I'm gonna give a school throw out X
number of million dollars for you to
wear our product okay I want the best
players wearing my product before they
go to the NBA and if you're on display
playing in big games actually televised
games and you're a good team I mean
let's it's just product placement is
what this is and that's what's going on
here
no do I think it happens everywhere just
about just about
because there's so much money involved
these coaches have to validate their
their salaries the schools want to make
the NCAA tournament the NCAA wants to
have a good product for March Madness
the TV executives want to have a good
product with March Madness and it all
comes down to the bottom line and that's
a billion-dollar multi-billion dollar
industry for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
you